welcome to Simply learns YouTube channel
today we take you to The Cutting Edge
world of AI in 2024 in the dynamic world
of AI and machine learning engineering
the possibilities are Limitless from
transforming raw data into actionable
insights to creating intelligent systems
that mimic human cognition this road map
is your passport to a future of
innovation we will now navigate through
the mathematical Bedrock explore the
neural intricacies of deep learning and
dive into the fascinating world of NLP
and computer vision and reinforcement
learning this journey encompasses real
world applications ethical
considerations and collaboration with a
Vibrant Community as we start the
journey remember the path is ever
evolving but your destination promises
to be at the Forefront of the
technological progress and discovery
that said if these are the type of
videos you'd like to watch then like
share and hit that subscribe button and
the bell icon to get notified as we
speak you might wonder what it takes to
become an expert artificial intelligence
and machine learning engineer if you are
a professional with minimum one year of
experience and an aspiring artificial
intelligence professional looking for
online training and certifications from
the prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts to
enhance your credibility then search no
more simply learns post graduate program
and artificial intelligence from Pur
University in collaboration with IBM is
just what you need for more details head
straight to our homepage and search for
artificial intelligence postgraduate
program from puru University or simply
click on the link in the description box
below now without further delay over to
our training developing expertise in Ai
and machine learning requires a
structured road map this Ai and machine
learning Road mapap tutorial can guide
you the aspiring Ai and ml Engineers can
follow this road map to build your
skills and knowledge with these fields
keep in mind that Ai and machine
learning are vast and rapidly evolving
areas so this road map is just a
starting point customize it based on
your interest and goals and you will be
the master of AI and ml so let's get
started with the first one that is the
prequisites so the first prerequisite is
mathematics prerequisites for AI and
machine learning begin with strong
foundation in mathematics encompassing
essential areas like linear algebra
calculus probability and statistics
mathematics underpins the algorithms and
models at the core of AI and machine
learning equally crucial is Proficiency
in programming particularly in languages
like python coding skills enable you to
translate mathematical Concepts into
practical Solutions and python with its
Rich libraries is a linga franka of the
field field Mastery of these
prerequisites empowers you to tackle
complex problems design algorithms and
unlock the potential of artificial
intelligence and machine learning moving
ahead is basic programming and data
handling basic programming and data
handling are foundational steps on the
AI and ml road map mastering python
fundamentals is essential as python is
the goto language for these fields next
dive into libraries like numpy and
efficient numerical operations pandas
for versatile data manipulation and
matte plot lip for data visualization
NPI AR is streamline mathematical tasks
while pandas simplifies data
organization cleansing and
transformation matplot lip crafts
compelling visuals these tools are your
building blocks empowering you to
efficiently process analyze and present
data setting the stage for more advanced
Ai and ml Concepts that aade on your
journey next is machine learning
fundamentals machine learning
fundamentals are the Cornerstone of AI
and ml it begins with grasping Core
Concepts and algorithms such as
regression which is predicting
continuous values classification which
is sorting data into categories and
clustering which is also grouping data
based on similarity these principles
under ai's predictive power to put them
into practice one must acain themselves
with psyit laar a python Library
celebrated for its Simplicity and
versatility in implementing machine
learning models with these fundamentals
you unlock the ability to make sense of
data extract valuable insights and
create intelligent systems making the
complex world of AI and machine learning
more accessible and Powerful followed by
this we have deep learning deep learning
stands as the PowerHouse of AI and
machine learning proping us into a realm
where computers emulate the complexity
of human brain this field dwells deep
into neural networks algorithms inspired
by biological neural structures it's
where machines learn to recognize
patterns make predictions and process
verst dates to embark on this journey
you must first solidify your grasp of
machine learning fundamentals next
acquaint yourself with popular deep
learning Frameworks such as tensor flow
and pytorch which streamline the
development and training of neural
networks these tools enable you to
construct intricate models optimizing
parameters and layers of various tasks
experimentation is the heart of deep
learning dive into building and training
neural networks starting with simple
models and gradually progressing into
more complex architectures discover how
convolutional neural networks that is
CNN Excel and computer vision while
recuring neural networks that is RNN
Master sequential data Gans or
generative aders neural networks even
enable creativity by generating new
content deep learning opens doors to
image and speech recognition autonomous
vehicles medical diagnosis and so much
more making it a pivotal component of AI
and machine learning advancement moving
ahead we have data pre-processing and
feature engineering data pre-processing
and feature engineering are vital steps
in Ai and machine learning data quality
is Paramount cleaning handling missing
values and scaling ensures reliable
model input feature engineering involves
creating meaningful variables from raw
data enhancing model performance it
demands domain knowledge transforming
data into a format more amendable to
machine learning techniques like one hot
encoding text tokenization and
dimensionality reduction refine features
proper data preparation reduces noise
AIDS model convergence and ultimately
yields more accurate predictions
mastering these steps is a key to
harnessing the full potential of AI and
machine learning learning algorithms
making your models smarter and efficient
and more productive the next one in the
list is model evaluation and validation
model evaluation and validation in Ai
and ml are prival steps in assessing a
models performance and ensuring its
reliability this involves a study of
cross validation techniques which help
gauge how well a model generalizes new
data metrics like accuracy precision
recall and F1 score provides
quantitative insights into its
Effectiveness understanding overfitting
that is the model learning and training
data to well and underfitting that is a
model's inability to capture underlying
patterns is essential to mitigate these
issues regularization techniques and
appropriate model complexity adjustments
must be employed effective validation
ensures that your model makes accurate
predictions and ready for real world
deployment moving ahead we have advanced
machine learning Advanced machine
learning in Ai and ml takes you beyond
the basics dwelling into sophisticated
techniques that supercharge your models
emble methods combine multiple models to
improve accuracy and reliability
dimensionality reduction methods and
streamline complex data enhancing model
efficiency and interpretability time
series analysis equips you to extract
valuable insights from sequential data
critical and forecasting and anamy
detection m of these Advanced Techniques
enables you to tackle real world
problems with finess making better
predictions optimizing resource usage
and focusing Trends with Precision it's
the key to elevating your AI and ml
expertise and crafting solutions that
Excel and complexity moving ahead we
have natural language processing NLP and
computer vision also known as CV natural
language processing and CV are
transformative branches of AI and ml in
NLP you decode the power of language
enabling machines to understand generate
and interact with human text or speech
dive deep into libraries like nltk and
Spacey for text analysis and processing
meanwhile computer vision and Powers
machines to interpret and make decisions
based on visual data and much like the
human eye tools like open CV and psyched
image are your allies in this realm both
Fields offer exciting opportunities for
those
with an interest in Bridging the Gap
between human cognition and artificial
intelligence transforming data into
actionable insights next in the list is
reinforcement learning reinforcement
learning or RL is a pivotal branch of AI
and ml where agents learn by trial and
error in Dynamic environments agents
like actions to maximize cumulative
rewards making RL essential for
autonomous systems Robotics and game AI
understanding reinforcement learning
algorithms like Q learning and policy
gradients is fundamental while
experimenting with environments in
reinforcement learning Frameworks such
as open AI gym allows you to train and
evaluate agents in diverse scenarios
reinforcement learning's ability to
tackle complex problems and adapt to New
Challenges makes it a transformative
field with applications ranging from
self-driving cars to gain strategy
optimization the 10th one in the list is
model deployment model deployment in Ai
and ml is the progress of taking your
trained machine learning model and
making it available for real world usage
it involves configuring and model to
work seamlessly in various environments
such as cloud services for scalable and
accessible Solutions or Edge devices for
low latency on device processing
deployment also necessitates monitoring
and updating models to ensure continued
accuracy by effectively deploying models
organiz ganizations can harness the
predictive power of AI and ml enhancing
decision making automating processes and
providing users with valuable insights
all while adapting to the specific needs
and constraints of their operational
environment next is specialization
specialization in AIML entails immersing
oneself into a chosen subfield such as
computer vision natural language
processing or robotics allowing for a
profound expertise by narrowing your
focus you can dwell deeper into the
intricacies of your area of Interest
this specialization requires staying
current with the latest research
attending conferences and exploring
Cutting Edge advancements with a
dedicated Focus you not only become a
subject matter expert but also
contribute to the ongoing evolution of
AI and ml unlocking innovative solutions
and pushing the boundaries of what's
possible in your chosen domain next is
real world projects real world projects
in AIML are The Crucible where
theoretical knowledge ignites into
practical Mastery firstly Hands-On
engagement through personal or
open-source projects allows you to craft
and deploy models solving real problems
and owning your skills secondly
platforms like kaggle offer a sneech to
compete and collaborate unleashing your
abilities in a competitive environment
these challenges mimic industry
scenarios from data analysis to
prediction and equip you with valuable
EXP experience real world projects are
when Theory meets application and the
Synergy of creativity and practicality
propels you forward in the ever evolving
landscape of AI and ml 13th Step In this
road map is continuous learning
continuous learning is the lifeblood of
success in EI and ml staying at The
Cutting Edge means constantly tracking
the latest strengths absorbing research
papers and adopting best practices the
field evolves rapidly demanding
adaptability online courses workshops or
formal education provide structured
avenues for skilled argumentation they
offer in-depth insights practical
exercises and networking opportunities
by embracing these educational resources
you can keep your knowledge current and
stay competitive in the ever advancing
domain where Innovation and growth are
nurtured through an unwavering
commitment to ongoing learning and
professional development next ahead is
networking Network working in Ai and
machine learning is crucial concept of
career growth and staying at the
Forefront of these ever evolving Fields
joining Ai and machine learning
communities allows you to share insights
access valuable resources and
collaborate on projects attending
conferences such as new IPS and icml
provides exposure to the latest research
and Innovations while fostering
connections with like-minded experts
connecting with professionals offers
opportunities for mentorship knowledge
EX ex change and potential career
prospects in this highly Dynamic domain
networking isn't just an option it's a
pathway to unlocking doors nurturing
ideas and keeping Pace with The Cutting
Edge of AI and ml advancements now the
15th step in this road map is
professional development professional
development in Ai and machine learning
involves actively seeking job
opportunities or research positions in
these fields whether in Academia indust
or research institutions as Ai and ml
roles are in high demand this step is
crucial for career advancements
simultaneously building a compelling
portfolio that showcases your projects
and skills is essential this portfolio
not only serves as a tangible evidence
of your expertise but also demonstrates
your ability to apply Ai and ML and real
world scenarios it can be a powerful
tool for securing job interviews and
research opportuni ities ultimately
propelling your career in this Cutting
Edge and rapidly evolving domain and now
comes the last step which is ethical
considerations ethical considerations in
AI ml are Paramount as creators and
stewards of this transformative
technology we must comprehend the
profound ethical implications it carries
this entails grappling with questions of
bias fairness transparency and
accountability in your algorithms to
ensure responsible development we must
must actively seek to rectify biosis
maintain transparency in decision making
processes and be prepared to account for
our model outcomes by proactively
addressing ethical dilemas we uphold the
principles of equality and social
responsibility striving to harness the
power of AI and ml for the betterment of
society while minimizing harm and
discrimination remember that this road
map is a guideline the field is dynamic
so adapt your learning path and as new
technologies and Trends emerge
continuous learning and practice are
essential to become proficient in Ai and
machine learning and with that we have
reached to the end of this session on
AIML road map for 2024 should you need
any assistance pbd or any other
resources used in this session please
let us know in the comment section below
and our team of experts we'll be more
than happy to help you as soon as
possible until next time thank you and
keep learning stay tuned for more from
Simply learn staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here